la semaine dernière dans un petit
village de gironde un enfant de 7 ans
était raccompagné chez lui par la police
c'est la faire de ce week end au monde
en a par nick pour l'empêcher de manger
à la cantine en effet la mairie avait
pris cette décision à cause des impayés
des parents qui devaient environ 900
euros à 900 euros de comptines si on
peut comprendre que les impayés soit
problématique la méthode choque
énormément
ce soir elle est avec nous charles et
merci d'être là vous êtes la maman de
wigan vous allez nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé exactement dans un instant
et puis il ya la mer la ville aussi qui
a parlé qui cautionne un peu voilà ce
qui s'est passé regardez petite vidéo
pour revenir sur cette affaire
jeudi dernier un policier municipal est
venu récupérer un enfant de 7 ans à
l'école sur décision de la maire de la
commune la raison sa maman n'a pas payé
la cantine contactée elle se dit
consterné je ne trouve pas ça normal
qu'il y ait un enfant parce que lui en
soit il à avoir quoi dans l'histoire on
fait quoi en virant qu'il allait payer
la cantine avec la mère de famille ne
conteste pas les faits elle doit bien
800 euros à la cantine scolaire
l'enfant connaît
nous on a une dette de cantine global de
17000 euros toutes les personnes qu'on a
contacté se sont engagés à faire des
règlements et de régulariser leurs bêtes
opel en attendant son fils n'ira pas à
la cantine
alors sur les avec nous et on entendait
où c'est vrai que ça a fait bondir tout
le monde cette affaire qu'est ce qui
s'est passé je suis allée votre willan à
7 ans notre petit garçon il était
raccompagné chez lui par un policier
pour qu'ils ne puissent pas manger à la
cantine ce qui se passe vous êtes chez
vous je suis chez moi ouais je suis à ma
fenêtre je vois le policier vous avait
prévenu avant à non pas du tout mais non
personne vous appelez de l'école pour
vous dire à ceux ci n'ont jamais redit
que si pourtant on dit qu'on vous
appelez vous avez dit que vous pouvez
pas rare cherchez pas ce que vous mangez
le travail le matin même à ce que mon
fils a des rendez vous l'après midi donc
j'ai parlé le matin même avec la
maîtresse que la directrice je lui dis
je récupère et wi lan
comme tous les jeudis en fait après la
cantine non non pas du tout d'accord et
donc là vous êtes chez vous et je le
vois passer à l'issue du tco coût on le
voit tous les matins il est très gentil
le policier oui j'aurai un petit garçon
avec moi je fais partie
non pas du tout et là je le vois surgir
de la voiture et courir jusqu'à mais
bella je suis choqué alors je leur
demande pourquoi vous avez un et mon
fils voilà c'est ça qu'est ce qui se
passe alors ils me l'on m'explique que
c'est passé comme ça lui il exécute les
ordres sur de la base école a appelé la
police voilà faut ramener le petit
willan suite voilà vu que sa mère ne
paie pas on va aller le chercher devant
toute l'école devant tous les copains
c'est ça les bienvenus saleté on va les
chercher au milieu de la cour pour le
ramener chez lui pour voir dans
malpropre dont et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé donc il au milieu de la cour votre
fils ouidane c'est qui qui vient
chercher la pole provisoire le colis ben
je n'étais pas moins fort mais c'est
venu dans le fer le policier est venu
d'en lancer jeu apparemment c'est comme
ça que ça c'est prison qu'ils ont vu
donc ses potes ont vu votre fils partir
avec le policier tous les petits copains
qui ont s'étend donc en soi c'est normal
c'est de leur arracher en prison en
prison mettez les sirènes
voilà c'est très traumatisant pour
wilate r puis pensait passer histoire
comment il a vécu ou ilan qu'est ce qui
vous a dit willan il était vraiment il
est rentré vous explique tout vent s'est
moqué de moi on m'a déjà là l'an prison
en juillet tu n'as rien fait n'est pas
ta faute l'histoire elle par deux mois à
la va statuer pas fautif c'est pas grave
vous en êtes voulu de ce qui lui
arrivait pas bah oui bien sûr évidemment
un bien sûr parce que alors
il a dû sentir humilié forcément alors
ils ont dit qu la mairie explique que
vous deviez près de 900 euros 2 continue
à 860000 70 euros 3 il paraît que vous
avez été menaçants sont d'hors jeu vous
dit tout voilà il dit la mère a dit vous
auriez team traçantes quand elle vous a
relancé pas du tout pas du tout sa part
lancé parce que déjà c'est moi qui lui
ai téléphoné dont elle relancer
personnes vous pouviez pas payer les 800
euros pour l'instant voilà moi je lui ai
dit quand je l'appelais avant ce jeudi 1
c'était le lundi quand même d'accord
voilà je lui dis que moi cette semaine
je ne pouvais pas me fait ch et la ville
d'à côté le trésor public j'ai dit que
je pouvais pas cette semaine que je me
rendrai la semaine d'après vous
travaillez le surnom d' accord donc
c'est compliqué 8,70 euros à sortir cc
non mais vous voulez la mercredi j'y
vais je vais régler un peu moins de la
moitié et je vais essayer de voir faire
un échéancier quelque chose pour
régulariser à 1 sur le
de ouidah elle était parfaitement au
courant ça s'est très bien passé mais
qui s'est passé pourquoi ont pris cette
décision de jeudi des dires ouidane il
mangera pas là quand on roule sur une
question parce que déjà elle me dit au
téléphone elle me dit oui mais elles
vous disent à la mer ou la mairesse oui
elle m'a dit par contre ben oui lane ne
sera pas reçu belge et d'écouté depuis
le début de la rentrée scolaire donc le
jeudi d'avant où ils allaient reçu à la
cantine ah bon
enfin elle a commencé à s'énerver elle
n'était même pas dans les clous dylan
soit pris la comptine matériel ne savais
même pas qu'il y en ait malgré vous
n'ayez pas payer le à lhassa çà et là de
la liane m'a raccroché au visage seul je
n'ai jamais vu enfin ça fait seulement
téléphone ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
ya une altercation téléphonique moral à
la mère est derrière elle a dû dire
écoutez ouidane s'il vient là diop et la
proviseure la directrice de l'école a
écrit ce n'était pas au courant c'est
sur le matin parce que ce sont des gens
bienveillants c'est une très bonne école
donc elle la paix dans le jeu c'est un
métier si elle l'avait su là elle me
l'aurait dit qu'est ce que vous a dit la
directrice de l'école brillants elle m'a
dit on mais très bien à ce que parce que
là c'est le début de l'année tous met en
place le suivi et tout ça elle m'a dit
bombay ce sera tous les jeudis pour le
pour s'essuyer lips et rendez vous et
c'est tout elle va papa elle mariée
indienne va pas
je pense surtout à votre enfant c'est
pour lui c'est traumatisant oui non au
niveau de la loi si vous voulez un
enfant ne peut pas du jour au lendemain
se retrouver privés de cantine pour
cause d'impayés êtes une affaire qui
date depuis deux ans déjà je crois
madame il me semble non c'est pas vrai
non mais je ne sais pas je vous demande
c'est ce qui avait été sinistrée ce qui
avait été écrit alors en général de
commencer dès comme un temps mené papier
la comptine ah en fait c'était toute
l'année dernière les 870 euros
correspondent aux cantines de mes deux
garçons parce qu'avoir l'aller n'est
passé au collège 7 et les cancers non
ils ont été scolarisés en janvier 2020
ça c'est janvier 2020 et au delà de 2009
et donc ça donc voilà ça forcément mieux
mais ce n'est pas alors et dans ces cas
là quand on ne peut pas payer ce qui
arrive très souvent malheureusement pour
des situations difficiles que
connaissent de travers ces gens il ya
plusieurs relances qui sont faites avant
d'arriver à cette extrémité avait eu des
rôles en ciel est ce que vous avez été
relancé on n'a jamais effectué
vous avez rencontré le directeur de
l'école louis alors j'ai créé en mars
2021 une personne à la mairie pour
régler la situation à qui j'ai donné un
ris parce qu'en fait au tout début j'ai
enfin c'était compliqué aussi il fallait
vraiment que je me rende sur place pour
régler les cantines là je leur ai donné
un rives mars 2021 à ce jour ils ont
tiré 27 euros 50 au moins 2000 a quand
même est ce que est ce qu'ils peuvent
retirer sur votre compte mais bien sûr
bref mathieu je suis très triste pour
cet enfant parce que c'est toujours un
traumatisme pour les enfants et on sait
où ces faits à quel point ça peut durer
soir chez vous après on va nous regarder
beaucoup à un cuir lacée après je vous
en veux un peu madame parce que vous
êtes la première à dire bastien bah du
coup on est en train de trouver une
solution pour pouvoir payer ça veut dire
que finalement ça a été efficace ce flic
qui est venu ça veut dire qu'il a fallu
en arriver là et punir ce gamin pour que
vous reparler cette affaire au sérieux
bah c'est un petit peu sa part
j'ai pas dit le contraire jouer du et je
dis pas que ça ne faisait exprès du pac
man si à côté j'ai jamais dis ça je dis
que malheureusement doivent aller il a
fallu ça et puis du coup vous venez de
prendre un accord maintenant pour
pouvoir payer et il rappelle que ça
parce que moi je l'appelais lundi
justement pour lui parler et ça s'est
produit après madame si vous étiez pas
une relance et s'est rien passé
c'est tout le monde cette famille ne
paye pas ce n'est pas par plaisir
séparée viable parce que j'étais le
contraire du monde va si on dirait qu'il
ya
des gens qui malheureusement n'ont pas
les moyens de payer la côte merci
guillaume grima la vie est belle
connerie ça plutôt que de les aider on
les humilie c'est dégueulasse mais on
les aide
[Applaudissements]
un milliard c'est bien beau mais bon
pour charles et oui merci à guillaume
pour ta leçon car c'est vrai merci n'a
pas de coeur voilà aider la
croix pas dire
que le problème c'est qu'on a plein de
versions différentes voilà ce qu'on a
plein de gens ont dit aussi que yayi
vous avez relancé on a dit aussi vous
avez un autre fils je crois dans une
arrivée en fait tout ça est confus parce
que l'école privée j'imagine que c'est
payant donc vous payer une école privée
le tri et à la courtine non mais j'ai
pas dit quel est le problème c'est pas
que j'aime pas les moyens de régler la
cantine le barème envers de leila de
résidence pourquoi l'otan qui s'est en
fait c'est l'accumulation des premières
factures qu'ils ont fait mais ce que je
comprends dans ce que dit mathieu c'est
qu'il manque des gels évidemment pas de
vous accablez parce que les situations
sont très difficiles mais quand on est
parent on a des droits et on a des
devoirs bien sûr images et tous qui
malgré tout bâti vous mettez dans une
situation très fin très compliqué il ya
quelque chose d' irresponsable pour
votre fils et comme par hasard vous avez
trouvé la solution maintenant que le
diam intéressé turquie auprès des siens
et laisser les 50 euros avait été
prélevé plus les factures la somme
s'élevait à environ 500 euros mais elle
serait déjà rattrapé depuis depuis un
petit moment il n'ya pas faim voilà moi
j'ai fait j'ai été au rendez vous quand
j'ai été convoqué là j'ai appelé la
mairesse c'est pas moi m'a jamais
convoqué elle a beau dire ce qu'elle
veut réellement fait tellement bien sûr
aucun calmant pour trèbes réellement
vous êtes mieux de relancer
après roland si j'en ai déroulant ce
d'impayés de la part du trésor public
évidemment bien sûr que j'aimerais sans
rentrer dans les détails et ce qui
serait pas mieux de punir entre
guillemets la merde finir l'amplitude et
de faire mine d'être chose d'être à
temps pour mes
passages à relais pardon je serais pas
où l'enfant là c'est le cas c'est pour
la plantation la mer et l'on parle de
l'enfant la lega et là c'est hyper grave
ce qui s'est passé pour lui ça peut être
un traumatisme à vie vous imaginez la
police fin nous quand on était petits la
police est un truc de dingue et c'est
n'auront plus tard puis prendre mon gros
ventre
[Applaudissements]
je suis un peu la creg géraldine fallait
penser un petit peu avant alors bien sûr
c'est facile de dire non j'oubliais
c'est de jeu pour apprendre la position
guillaume et dire bah oui quand on n'a
pas d'argent c'est difficile la vie tout
ça on est d'accord fallait penser aussi
à double approche me savoir que ça
finira par arriver et ce gamin
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est un
traumatisme quand même si aujourd'hui
les six essais d'autres foot gilles
verdez rien justifie mathieu rien ne
justifie aujourd'hui en francs de
prendre un enfant bien sûr un policier
heureusement il était armé à la cantine
l'aura mené le qu'il voit sa maman
humilié afficher sa maman devant lui
c'est le onze qui s'est passé la mairie
de la ville
c'est toute l'asie c'est tout le monde
paie s'agit laissez moi
encore les publics en fait oui lot
d'impayés dans la vie on a eu marre elle
a pris un exemple elle s'est dit je
reste à payer
se confondent et il avait le droit de
manger non non vous pouvez télécharger
sur les jeux sur les je suis revenu je
pense qu'elle a été prise pour exemple
voilà et en s'assurant
et nous manque des éléments c'est
difficile d'évaluer une situation qu'on
leur demande et lui n'ont cessé leurs
difficultés quelles sont vos ressources
parce que nous on voulait dire semapa
brune d'argent vous êtes dire départ
bien sûr que non là alors c'est à brême
de coincer les les dettes qui se sont
accumulés a quand même parce qu'en fait
il faut se rendre à moi je ne suis pas
véhiculer là c'est la ville d'à côté
pour aller régler la cantine et j'ai on
n'a pas les factures donc forcément on
ne pense pas qu'à la cantine du du début
du moins c'est ce et puis qu'après quand
on a quelques factures de retard c'est
là où ça devient compliqué a
actuellement c'est compliqué bien sûr
vite 5 ans à 10 ans je relaie ce que
vous dites que vous êtes à
isa c'est qu'au départ vous n'avez pas
payé la cantine ça c'est n'est pas payé
pendant des mois et là vous vous
retrouvez avec une somme qui est quand
même très importante puisque c'est plus
de presque 900 euros et que là
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas la payer
forcément 7,6 troupes là je vais le
mercredi je vais pouvoir régler une
bonne partie moi j'avais pas réglé la
bonne partie va je vais pas mentir et un
petit peu moins à beaucoup ma mère
d'accord là donc c'est ça vous avez
aussi on peut comprendre aussi que j'en
avais pas envie de demander la voulait
se démerder sûr mais c'est dégueulasse
parce que là on a le mauvais rôle avec
géraldine alors que ya d'autres familles
monoparentales qui s'est brûlé et
c'est tous les gens qui n'avaient pas
payé ne payez pas un fardeau mais
comment on ferait un moment on parle pas
revenir à nos six conseils déchets qui a
été ramené chez lui mais marc poulin
est en plus très sympa le police il
paraît que gêné oui le policier était
gêné riad pour faire cette besogne fait
même où il était obligé de le faire mais
le pauvre il s'est dit ben c'était pas
facile pour lui je peux vous dire est
content il avait le petit dans l'ordre
la voiture pour lui c'est un c'est un
mauvais moment je veux dire quand il est
rentré le soir chez lui le policier n'a
envie de l'anc s'est pas envie de faire
ce à quoi s'est passé va pour ça que je
devais du policier oui nycomed et je
peins mélanger et de sujets oui votre
problème c'est que vous savez très bien
que vous aurez tous vous pouvez toujours
avoir un échéancier avec une mairie donc
à un moment donné il fallait parler avec
la mairie éprouvé un échéancier pour
pouvoir
et vous dites que vous avez donnée à rim
et que en fait c'est eux qui n'ont pas
utilisé au tribe c'est là où ça ne tient
pas la route par rapport à l'enfance qui
était celle du véhicule aujourd'hui ce
sont les parents qui doivent être punis
un moment donné et qu'il faut aller
chercher les parents et leur demander de
trouver un accord comme tout le monde il
faut savoir via des médiateurs
aujourd'hui aussi des voix le petit
crâne n'est pas la police ça s'annonce
assez scandaleux bien sûr
c'est un problème d'adultes aujourd'hui
je vois la condamne fermement ce qui
s'est passé avec l'enfant bien
évidemment génère cette mention il va
être choqué
personne
je n'achete aurait dû se passer pour moi
pour moi la mairesse ou la directrice de
la mairesse voulez pas vous parler
puisque vous avez un petit accrochage
avec elle elle aurait dit à la
directrice de l'école 2 vous a plu j'ai
eu un appel de la mairie me disant que
si vous ne payez pas dans quinze jours
trois semaines rue on pourra pas
accueillir willan à la cantine vous vous
auriez où je paye ou bien je fais
revenir mon fils le midi et au moins
comme ça personne ne le sait voilà mais
au moins la prévenir puis voilà est-ce
qu'on peut trouver un arrangement ou
bien est ce que vous voulez que le voilà
par exemple le dit n'importe quoi le 1er
octobre iny pinétois plus accueillis à
la cantine et vous prenez vos
dispositions pour le prendre chez vous
ça au moins elle aurait pu dans la série
la mise ces fonds auraient pu éviter
cette scène dégueulasse du poti qui
ramollit devancé colas et bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
non mais attends je veux bien vous
applaudir sauf que la mairesse elle dit
que c'est ce qui a été fait mais une
fois qu'elle propose à sion plein de
sommation selanne a dit qu'il va étaler
renate la lettre a mené par la police
non je ne crois pas eu
si vous ne réglez pas de suite pas moi
un autre parent votre enfant lui donnera
du pain dur et de l'eau vous si vous ne
réglez pas votre l'unique facture que
mon ami devait par rapport au fait
qu'elle n'ait pas reçu les factures vous
la carte de bus qui est gratuite qui n'a
rien à voir votre carte de bus vous
l'aurez pas en fait si aujourd'hui j'ai
pas le paiement je vous laisse jusqu'à
jeudi en fait alors que mon ami lui dit
je viens je dis bien joué jusqu'à jeudi
s'il vous n'avez pas la carte de bus est
ce que c'est normal ça non pas vous même
si les services sociaux c'est normal ça
alors il se sera bien parlé à la
mairesse louise savard et à la décence
alors aujourd'hui willan il est donc l
etat mais will hahn il est pas bien il
retourne à l'école il est retourné à
l'école louis pas à la cantine à l'aube
dimanche chez vous actuellement loi
lacey ces accords qu'est ce qu'ils ont
dit c'est ses petits camarades mais l'on
par rapport à l'histoire ballon
ils ont ils leur expliquer ce qui s'est
passé je ne sais pas je n'ai pas c'est
pas un grand bavard c'est pas un centime
en emploi ni sachez qu'on parle de cette
histoire qui a fait énormément parler ce
week-end le petit wydad qui a été ramené
par la police chez lui parce que sa
maman n'avait pas payé la cantine et
c'est vrai que ça nous a tous choqués et
vous avez une discussion avec lui vous
lui avez oui oui je le dis c'est pas ta
faute
le problème il parle de maman mais tout
ça s'arrangerait mais dû arriver parce
que tu étais pas le fautif comme je lui
puisqu'en fait souvent on dit aux
enfants qu'est ce qu'on leur dit aux
enfants alors dit la police ils arrêtent
les méchants les voleurs voilà donc lui
il s'est senti
été arrêté par la police la police marne
et maman c'est grave il m'a dit non
parce qu'en soit le policier il était
très cool oui il a dit oui mais tu es
mon copain c'est pourquoi je te ramène
il est brave à lui parce que ça s'est
passé devant l'école alors salle de
l'école avec des camarades et ses
camarades cette scène là qu'il a à
partir avec la voiture de police voilà
c'est ça allait chercher au wi lan pense
elle à la cantine et finalement
changement de programme c'est cette
partie là que je dénonce je construis il
avait le lendemain de retourner à
l'école
peur parce que c'est quand même enfin
j'veux pas qu'on respecte et il était
militant il avait l'appréhender voilà
c'est ça dès qu'on lui pose des
questions oui je penserai qu'est ce que
lui vous savez ce qui est en train de
s'écrire les deux trois jours en fait
avec savoir
puisque week-end on lance un petit peu
plus qu'est ce qui vous a dit ce
week-end mais qu'il est triste qui est
pour lui ce sens ils se sont dits unis
ils se sentent unis alors qu'il n'a rien
fait que la faute vient de moi il se
sent puni j'en ai voulu de ben voilà sur
évidemment évidemment avoir scellé les
choses avant vous verrez ça se
reproduira plus je vais tout faire pour
c'est un enfant qui est heureux en plus
la salle enfants très heureuse un enfant
très dynamique vous aurez des retours je
pense que c'est ça il est idéal oui il
est là adacore on très bien et bien
voulons montrer notre part et je vais
vous dire on va s'occuper de cette dette
de cantine comme ça au moins ce sera
fait
nous avec la production va s'occuper de
cette dette de cantine donc c'est on va
la prendre en charge
[Applaudissements]
à tout ce qui se passe non il n'y a rien
c'est que
ça commence à me touche on passe pour
les méchants ce que je te dis juste
madame j'ai rien contre je trouve ça
juste dur on triste qu'il ait fallu en
arriver là pour que vous trouviez une
simple solution tout [ __ ] avec 10 à une
école direz vous n'auriez trouvé la
solution vous avez pris le problème à la
légère aujourd'hui c'est votre fils qui
a payé la pelle indienne et s'avancer
rien quand on vous écoute vous avez tout
fait comme il faut il ya un fil ténu
mais c'est pas exactement
écoutez en tee shirt invite à aller
faire un petit tour dans la commune je
vous appelle parce qu'il sait c'est
vraiment pour des cons voilà et oui la
dent tout cas alerte résurrection sachez
le joli de ce qu'on sait et il est très
heureux et sa maman s'occupe très bien
de lui et voilà là c'est vrai qu'a eu
cette mauvaise aventure on espère que
will hahn va s'en sortir voilà en tout
cas je vous dis on appris las d'être là
de cette cantine est pour vous je vous
le demande a décidé de vous offrir un
nom de course
et l'ancien
c'est une honte c'est qu'ils ont appris
qu a été très touchée par votre affaire
le savez qu'on bourre ce soir et elle a
dit ben nous on prend en charge un antre
où ça l'a même pas voulu qu'on la cites
voilà dit voilà salluste ont été touchés
par l'histoire de will hahn donc on a
décidé d'offrir un an de courses à
shirley à wil hahn et à votre famille
donc voilà j'espère qu'en tout cas ça va
s'arranger que ti willan va oublier
cette mauvaise aventure et vous souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur c'est très gentil
alors merci on peut remercier cette
personne merci pour pour tout ça est
encore derrière d'adobe pas voilà pour
que ça se reproduise plus voilà donc ça
ne s'est pas aux enfants de payer vous
avez pleuré les parties non mais là j'ai
envie ben c'est normal
[Applaudissements]